wildfires are burning within 17
kilometers of Yellowknife the capital
city of Canada's Northwest Territories
officials say it's time for the city's
twenty thousand residents to leave
please take this order seriously and
prepare to leave the City by noon on
Friday
officials already have started
airlifting other provincial residents
who can't drive themselves to safety
those who can drive may need police
escort to help them navigate
smoke-filled highways emergency
Personnel say right now the weather is
working against them there is a
possibility that Without Rain the fire
reaches the outskirts of Yellowknife by
the weekend it is approaching but
there's time to complete the community
evacuation
twenty thousand square kilometers of
land have already burned across the
province the Prime Minister has promised
logistical and financial support to
local authorities
some 6 800 evacuees have already headed
south to Alberta for the time being but
they have no idea when they can return
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera
now Paige Parsons is a CBC reporter who
joins us live from Edmonton in Alberta
Canada good to have you with us so how
is the effort going to try and stop
those fires from reaching Yellowknife
yes as you as we just heard uh the
evacuation order came last night and
it's nearly 22 000 people that are
fleeing their homes in in Yellowknife
the capital city of the Northwest
Territories and something important for
folks to understand is this community is
it's quite far north I'm in Edmonton and
they're about it's about a 15-hour drive
to get from Yellowknife to Edmonton so
it's it's significant and it's not
um folks are both being airlifted out
but many of them if they're able they've
been asked to drive and this highway
it's not like something we'd have here
more in southern Canada or in more
populated parts of the world it's it's
very remote you're traveling through
remote areas there's very few services
so what we've heard is that traffic on
the highway it's very heavy and when you
do reach a spot where they're the one of
the few spots where there is gas there's
been significant lineups some of those
places have run out of gas but the
government is sending supports up and
down the highway gas trucks tow trucks
that kind of thing to try to help people
as they're you know making this very
significant uh Journey the closest
evacuation Center is over a thousand
kilometers away from Yellowknife so
people really do have quite a distance
to go to get to safety and for people
that can't drive for people who are
vulnerable or with with children there's
also an air evacuation going on we have
several flights coming into Calgary uh
more in Southern Alberta today as well
as a few going into Vancouver and what's
happening to people Paige you mentioned
that being evacuated to where what
conditions are they facing
certainly so
for the folks that are driving as
they're they're driving down uh through
very smoky conditions you know a lot of
the Northwest Territories is
experiencing fires there's fires
everywhere and while the highway has
been deemed safe it's you know it's not
a not an easy or or comfortable drive
for folks and once they do reach one of
the communities uh which which is
accepting evacuees which there are now
several there's some of the smaller
communities uh or medium-sized cities in
Northern Alberta there are evacuation
centers set up um you know places where
people can rest uh get some get some
basic supplies folks we're told to bring
you know about 72 hours worth of food
and
survival supplies with them in their
cars when they left Yellowknife so if
they need to they can go to these
evacuation centers which are across
Northern Alberta and now there's a very
large one being set up at the Calgary
Airport that will receive the people
that are flying in and for they've
actually asked you know a lot of people
up north they'll have relatives they'll
have friends down here in Alberta and so
if you're able to they're asking you
know to to go there to to you know make
sure that the resources there's enough
resources for everyone so if you're able
to stay with family and friends um you
know that could help leave space in
these evacuation centers which
unfortunately we've become very used to
setting up here in Alberta for Wildfire
evacuees so you have cots food water
that kind of thing
all right thanks so much Paige Parsons